the funeral for Stephon Clarke will take
place today in Sacramento police shot
and killed the 22 year old on March 18th
they mistakenly thought he had a gun
Clarke's death led to days of intense
protests that spread last night to New
York City Jamie yuccas is in Sacramento
with today's funeral plans Jamie good
morning good morning Clark's funeral
will be held here at boss shirt it is
open to the public
civil rights leader Reverend Al Sharpton
will deliver the eulogy
he's expected to talk about Clark's life
and how his death plays into perceived
injustice and police shootings this
latest protest over the police killing
of Stephan Clark started at the
sacramento county district attorney's
office before quickly evolving into a
march through the city streets activists
blocked traffic at a busy downtown
intersection during rush hour in new
york city wednesday demonstrators made
their way from Columbus Circle to Times
Square police detained nearly a dozen
people when protests turned violent it's
been almost two weeks since Clark was
shot dead in his grandparents backyard
after police thought he was vandalizing
property officers believed the father of
two had a gun he had a cell phone
White House press secretary Sarah
Sanders said on Wednesday that the
administration does not plan to get
involved in the matter the president is
very supportive of law enforcement but
at the same time in these specific cases
and these specific instances those would
be left up to local authorities to make
that determination and not something for
the federal government to weigh into
Benjamin Crump is a civil rights
attorney representing the Clark family I
completely disagree with the White House
press secretary and anybody else who is
trying to marginalize this to just a
local matters as a national issue we
must solve it as Americans
Crump tells CBS this morning that while
the family is grateful to the protesters
they are hoping that today is peaceful
and a celebration of Clark's life the
family also says they're going to
release their own independent autopsy
results in coming days Gail yeah there's
still a lot of questions about that it
is interesting the tactic appears to be
changing to make this a local issue when
clearly when you look at all the
incidents around the country this is a
national problem it's better yep there
is a pattern it seems more not so much
about black and white although that
seems to be certainly part of it but how
about right and wrong
yeah it's very disturbing on many levels
greater things on top of this story I
think so Jimmy yuccas